my name is lin-manuel miranda and i am
the writer of hamilton and i also play
alexander hamilton hi i'm thomas kale i
play the character of the director
of the movie of hamilton hi my name is
jasmine cephas jones and i play
peggy schuyler and mariah reynolds in
hamilton hi my name is renee elise
goldsberry i play angelica schuyler in
hamilton
and my name is leslie odom jr i play
aaron byrne hamilton what's up everybody
christopher jackson from hamilton hi my
name is oak i played hercules mulligan
and james madison what's up i'm anthony
ramos and i played uh
john lawrence and philip hamilton hello
i'm philippa zu
and i played eliza skyler hamilton
we're taking a buzzfeed quiz together
and the headline of that quiz is
which hamilton and disney characters are
you a perfect combo of
how would your friends describe you
easygoing
passionate adventurous sarcastic
clumsy goofy generous
kind-hearted kind-hearted all right
tommy's choice is kind-hearted
i'm going to go with can i answer for
you
yes you are my friend what would you say
passionate oh thank you
i guess sarcastic is that true
anthony and pips is it's a thousand
percent i think you anthony
are like there's a passionate and
there's also a goofy easy going
i'll say i say for me passionate me
i would say generous just from whenever
you're on stage in life you're just so
you're sitting i'm so generous you guys
i'm gonna say passionate
just because that covers a lot of bases
i'll say
kind-hearted i think i'm easygoing but i
don't know that my friends would always
agree with me
i'm thinking kindhearted would win i
would hope people would say i was
generous
but i feel like if they were presented
with this list they would say easygoing
first who would you choose as your
sidekick
abu from aladdin flounder from the
little mermaid
olaf from frozen tinkerbell from peter
pan
pumbaa from the lion king mushu from
mulan
pascal from tangled or piglet
the new adventures of winnie the pooh i
love mushu i feel like
tinkerbell has some powers does she
could she can she bless you can take her
fellowship
could i get blessed if i picked your
bell and then you could always like put
a little dixie cup over her
look you're trying to sleep so i'm gonna
take your belt like a sidekick you gotta
spend
all day every day with them i'm gonna
choose a boo i think he'd be a really
good friend
loyal you have a laugh with him you have
adventures with him
he's tough he's gonna like help you in a
fight i'ma choose that boot
it's gotta be mushu from mulan because
you know
mushu piglet and that's ten times out of
ten
i think i'm going with flounder
flounder yeah god you're so predictable
i got pumbaa 100 i'm gonna go with a boo
because he has thumbs i think mine
might be what is your favorite part of a
story
the quirky characters the fairy tale
ending the wild adventures
the soundtrack the love interests the
life lessons they teach
the villain or the setting i like the
wild adventures right
i'm down for you know some swashbuckling
the quirky characters was that an option
that was the first option and i'm gonna
go with that i'm gonna love that for
your journey
i'm going to go with the soundtrack or
if you're a broadway pet aunt
the original cast album this soundtrack
come on
i'm gonna pick life lessons i think i'm
gonna do the quirky characters
so you be playing the quirky characters
i understand
you're drawn to them the adventures i
like all the stuff in the middle
well i'm the life lessons they teach
surprise
what about the villain it makes the
story good i mentioned that one
which disney princess do you vibe with
most jasmine from aladdin belle
from beauty and the beast ariel from the
little mermaid cinderella from
cinderella
tiana from the princess and the frog
pocahontas from pocahontas moana from
moana mulan
from a lot i'd have to go with mulan
because she's just about that life 100
i'm going with that
i love moana though she got the island
vibes you know my family from puerto
rico
even though that wasn't set in puerto
rico but it still just reminds me every
time i watch that movie
it just it just reminds me of like my
roots and you know what
what puerto rico makes me feel like what
was the last one
moana from moana that's one of the
disney movies
yes is it good you saw it early and
don't pretend you didn't
ariel you're going with ariel you
actually make my choice
easier because that's my default but i'm
going to go with moana
that's the movie you were talking about
that has like the girl right
he's like trying to leave the island
yeah yeah how far she'll go tiana
princess and the frog i mean tiana i
love mulan
she's courageous she did not want her
dad to fight in that war
so she escaped she chopped her hair off
she fought
she's amazing i seem to remember that in
the end
of aladdin jasmine is not a princess she
is the emperor
and this world needs to see some women
ruling we need
to understand we need to be okay we need
to recognize that until we can see
leadership coming from women we might
not have the change that we want
uh-huh i'm going to pick jasmine from
aladdin i'm choosing tiana man i spent i
spent some time in new orleans at the
top of this year
they're they're just i think they're my
favorite people in this country like
you know oh sh i'm from philly i love
me you know i love everybody but there's
really something special
there's something special about the
accent there's something special about
the food and the way of life in new
orleans i i was
i fell in love a little bit so i'm
choosing tiana
pick a song for karaoke hey outcast
single ladies beyonce
no scrubs tlc toxic britney spears
we belong together mariah carey bye bye
bye and
sync rolling in the deep adele or i want
to dance with somebody
whitney houston i didn't hear anything
after no scopes oh dear
toxic britney spears we belong together
oh no no meaning like
once you said no scrubs oh you were done
that's my choice
for just the fact that there's a
two-four bar in the middle of a 4-4 song
i'm picking hey y'all by outcast
it's gotta be hey y'all right got a
little cast hey yeah i'm doing hey
outcast three thousand eighty aliens up
in this
toxic for me bye bye bye all day long
come on
what i'm rolling in the deep i'd
probably pick i wanna dance with
somebody
just so i could put the emphasis on
somebody you know i'm gonna dance with
somebody
with somebody i like to go left
a little bit in karaoke and sing a song
that is
unexpected but out of these songs i
would probably sing a little britney
spears song
you know maybe i could do a little
something with it now tell us your
favorite hamilton song
is it yorktown is it wait for it is it
satisfied
is it guns and ships is it non-stop
you'll be back is it helpless or is it
one last time
mean it's a mean question yo chris sings
that one last time in the movie though
oh my gosh he does it's a new favorite
because it's a single
song wafer is one of my favorite
favorite songs you saying that every
night man
i think it's such a beautiful song so no
i'ma choose the non-stop
it's like it's a jam but there's also
storytelling in it i love that it
involves
everybody like i love everybody's piece
in it wait for it
for it yeah wait for it hands down
that's the banger that's the banger on
the album i think we all know where
we're going with that one right
one last time i could pick any of these
on any given day but today i will pick
wait for it satisfied finally which
character would you trust with a secret
aaron burr george washington or kelly's
mulligan
phillip hamilton angelica schuyler eliza
hamilton
peggy skyler alexander hamilton eliza
skyler
all day every day i have to agree with
you i try to be a contrarian but i'm
also going with eliza
probably gonna pick angelica skyler
because you know she keeps secrets
i'd have to go with the spy hercules
mulligan i think
he could keep i would trust angelica
skyler
i would trust burr like my man don't
talk badly i mean he talks himself
only i would do hercules mulligan
because he was a spy
on the inside i'm i was gonna pick a pig
eliza
but i'm a pig peggy i feel like all
these people have snitching tendencies
like i feel like
oh they do you know what i mean like
because they wrote letters dude they all
were
super gossipy eliza might be the one if
i had to tell her a
secret eliza would keep it i'm choosing
eliza boom
i got thomas jefferson and flynn rider
from tangled
i got aaron burr and aladdin from
aladdin
hey we are brother and sister leslie i
got
thomas jefferson and flynn rider from
tangled turns out folks that i got
angelica skyler and magara from hercules
i got the uh angelica and meg from
hercules
i got thomas jefferson and flynn rider
from tangled
i got philip hamilton skull
and simba that is so
dope that's a crazy combo yeah they work
so well together
you got thomas jefferson and flynn rider
from
tangled i think it's funny that we took
different choices every time and still
got the same results
what kind of test is this tommy's a very
wide algorithm
we took different routes to the same
place i choose to celebrate that
[Music]
you